foreign
boxed for our AMD Radeon RX 7800 XT
review yes Steve is still a little bit
sick so I will be presenting his review
for you all today normally we'd have a
GPU here to show you on the table so
just pretend that we've got one and it's
sitting here maybe we'll see GI that in
later I'm sure you see some b-roll but
anyway 7800
XT review so let's get into it today's
video is sponsored by bitdefender Total
Security and award-winning software
solution to protect your devices with no
compromise to Performance bitdefender
offers multi-layer threat protection to
combat many forms of attack including
ransomware and zero day exploits keeping
you safe against increasingly
sophisticated threats it also works to
keep your privacy intact featuring tools
to detect and prevent unauthorized
webcam and microphone access as well as
blocking web trackers that are looking
to steal your data if you're worried
about performance like we all are here
at Hardware unboxed bitdefender detects
activity like gaming sessions halting
pop-ups and unimportant background
activities during those crucial periods
of intense system usage Bit Defender
Total Security offers protection across
five devices including those running
Windows Mac OS Android and iOS so to
learn more and protect your Hardware
today at a great price click the link in
the description below at this point it's
hard to think of the 7800 XT as new
despite this being the first time we've
been able to show you it and that's
because the first rdna3 base gpus were
released last year back in December of
2022 when we got the 7900 XT and the XTX
model that's pretty crazy and I don't
think there has ever been a time in
history where AMD or Nvidia took nine
months to release the bulk of their
product stack normally after nine months
we'll be looking at refreshed or updated
products not a continuation of the
initial release cycle but here we are
amd's finally releasing the successor to
the impressive three-year-old 6800 XT so
what have they got for us well on paper
they look quite similar and it's hard to
imagine the 7800 XT will be much if any
step forward the core count has been
reduced by 17 though the cores are
clocking eight percent higher but based
on that alone you'd expect the 7800 XT
to be slower thankfully some upgrades to
the memory system have been made the
infinity cache capacity has been halved
but the bandwidth has been increased by
63 percent then we see while the same
256-bit wide memory bus is in use the
newer model receives faster 19.5
gigabits per second memory which has
increased the memory bandwidth by 22
percent so it's significantly more cash
and memory bandwidth the 7800 xt's fewer
cores will be able to work much harder
but it's still difficult to imagine it
being much faster than the 6800 XT in
most games also what I think is most
interesting about the 7800 XT is the
price just 500 us which is much lower
than the 600 us that myself and Steve
were expecting it's also at all odds
with the rest of the rdna3 lineup the
7900 XTX for example cost 10.41 per
compute unit and the XT version was a
bit worse at 10.71 the 7800 XT though
comes in at 8.33 per compute unit a 20
discount when compared to the XTX
basically AMD had two options here
priced the 7800 XT in line with the 7900
series resulting in terrible reviews and
sales forcing them to drop prices
basically what we saw with the 7900 XT
if I were a betting man this is what I
would have put money on AMD doing
because their ability to read the market
and learn as they go hasn't been all
that impressive to date the second
option was to read the room face reality
and price the 7800 XT accordingly the
least likely of the two options in my
opinion this option would see them drop
the 7800 XT well below the expected 600
us asking price to something much more
acceptable like 500 dollars and lo and
behold that's what they did
now I did say in my most recent monthly
GPU pricing update video that if the
7800 XT was to deliver 6800 XT like
performance it would need to cost no
more than 450 us and while we're yet to
look at the performance the 7800 XT is
at least priced much closer to our ideal
price certainly much more so than most
other AMD and Nvidia current generation
gpus that we've seen to date so that's
good but of course we have to check out
the performance
for testing we're using our ryzen 7
1700x3d test system with 32 gigabyte of
ddr5 6000 memory using the latest
display drivers all data has been
validated and updated for this video and
I'll be using the AMD reference version
of the 7800 XT in total I've tested 16
games well Steve's tested all of them
but yeah he's tested 16 games and we'll
only look at the individual results for
around a dozen of them with and without
Ray tracing before checking out the
average performance and of course the
cost per Frame data but please note all
graphs will be made available to patreon
and float plan members okay let's take a
look at what we have
starting with the playtail Requiem we
see that the new 7800 XT is delivering
6800 XT like performance at 1080p making
it slightly faster than the RTX 4070 and
about on par with the RTX 3080
then at 1440p we're seeing identical
performance to that of the 6800 XT with
88 FPS on average making it nine percent
faster than the RTX 4070 so certainly
nothing new here in terms of performance
though it's also quite reasonable given
the 500 us MSRP interestingly at the 4K
resolution the 7800 XT slips behind the
old 6800 XT by a 12 margin with 51 FPS
so a very disappointing result there
despite beating the RTX 4070 by a rather
large 11 margin
next up we have Resident Evil 4 and
starting with the 1080p data we see that
the 7800 XT is once again delivering
6800 XT like performance and that saw it
roughly on par with the RTX 4070 and RTX
3080. increasing the resolution to 1440p
doesn't change much the 7800 XT is
basically just a 6800 XT here making it
a few frames faster than the RTX 4070
then at 4K we're again faced with 6800
XT like performance from the 7800 XT
rendering 74 FPS on average to make it
12 faster than the RTX 4070
moving on to cyberpunk 2077 we have our
first example where the 7800 XT is
actually faster than the 6800 XT though
we're only talking about an eight
percent uplift at 1080p
still that was enough to beat the RTX
4070 by a nine percent margin the 7800
XT fares even better at 1440p with 95
FPS on average allowing it to match the
7900 GRE to come in nine percent faster
than the 6800 XT and 16 faster than the
RTX 4070 then at the 4K resolution
performance dropped to just 45 FPS on
average but still the 7800 XT was 22
faster than the RTX 4070
we're back to 6800 XT like performance
in Hogwarts Legacy where the 7800 XT
rendered 111 FPS making it 16 faster
than the RTX 4070 frame rates dropped to
88 FPS at 1440p but even so that still
meant the 7800 XT was 22 percent faster
than the RTX 4070 then at the 4K
resolution the margin over the RTX 4070
shrinks to 13 and once again in terms of
performance the 7800 XT looks to be a
6800 XT
next up we have Forza Horizon 5 and you
guessed it 6800 XT like performance from
the new 7800 XT making it a little
faster than the RTX 4070
jumping up to the 1440p resolution the
7800 XT was good for 140 FPS making it
just 2 FPS faster than the 6800 XT so
basically the same performance there and
that meant it was eight percent faster
than the RTX 4070 then at the 4K
resolution the 7800 XT was good for 101
FPS which is a 12 increase over the RTX
4070 but just a four percent boost over
the old 6800 XT
now Spider-Man remastered is a very rare
example where the 7800 XT is a good bit
faster than the 6800 XT delivering 11
more performance at 1080P and yet
despite that it's slightly slower than
the RTX 4070 the margin over the 6800 XT
was reduced to just 8 at 1440p while it
was just three percent slower than the
RTX 4070 though the one percent lows
were much better then at the 4K
resolution the 7800 XT is just six
percent faster than the 6800 XT and a
mere two percent slower than the RTX
The Last of Us Part One saw the 7800 XT
rendering 111 FPS at 1080p to pull ahead
of the 6800 XT by a mere 5 margin still
that meant it was 10 faster than the RTX
4070 then at 1440p we're looking at 81
FPS on average which is a 7 increase
over the 6800 XT and RTX 3080 and an
impressive 11 boost over the RTX 4070
jumping up to 4K the 7800 XT is able to
match the RTX 3080 while it was just a
frame slower than the 7900 GRE and two
frames slower than the 6950 XT it was
also seven percent faster than the 6800
XT and a massive 26 percent faster than
the RTX 4070
the last game we're going to look at for
the individual results is fortnite and
here the 7800 XT doesn't do all that
well coming in well behind the 7900 gra
and 6800 XT as it Trails by a 14 margin
at 1080p the same 14 performance deficit
to the 6800 XT remained at 1440p and
that meant the 7800 XT was 16 slower
than the RTX 4070 then finally at 4K the
7800 XT was nine percent slower than the
6800 XT and 10 slower than the RTX 4070s
so some disappointing numbers for the
7800 XT in fortnite
okay so here's a look at our 15-game
average which largely focuses on
rasterization performance though not
entirely as Forza Horizon 5 and f122
were tested using the maximum quality
preset which does enable Ray tracing but
we'll look at more RT focused data
shortly for now we see that at 1080p the
7800 XT is generally just a 6800 XT in
terms of performance which also meant it
was comparable with the RTX 3080 and RTX
4070 beating the more expensive 4070 by
a three percent margin
we're of course seeing much the same at
1440p the 7800 XT was a whisker slower
than the 7900 GRE which meant it was
just a few frames faster than the 6800
XT so another three percent uplift in
this example
still despite being 100 us cheaper than
the RTX 4070 the 7800 XT was six percent
faster on average so at least relative
to nvidia's current generation offerings
the 7800 XT does look very good now at
the 4K resolution the 7800 XT and 6800
XT were neck and neck but even so the
new 500 Radeon GPU is still nine percent
faster than the RTX 4070 so while pretty
unexciting when compared to the 6800 XT
if you're coming from a much older GPU
the 7800 XT might actually be of
interest
here's a closer look at how the 7800 XT
and 6800 XT compared across the 15 games
tested at 1440p as we saw the 1700 XT
was on average just three percent faster
but overall we have an interesting
spread of results the newer rdna 3 GPU
really struggled in fortnite and Dying
Light 2 while it offered nothing extra
in half a dozen more titles the only
worthwhile wins were seen in Call Of
Duty Modern Warfare 2 and Warhammer 3.
then versus the RTX 4070 we see that
although the 7800 XT was six percent
faster on average the data is once again
all over the place the Radeon GPU
crushed it in Modern Warfare 2 Hogwarts
Legacy cyberpunk 2077 and The Last of Us
Part 1 but also struggled in fortnite
while coming up shortly in Hitman 3 Halo
infinite Spider-Man and Dying Light 2.
okay so let's take another look at
performance in a plague tail Requiem but
this time with Ray tracing enabled with
rt enabled the 7800 XT was limited to 67
FPS on average at 1080p in our test
which is a six percent improvement over
the 6800 XT but 26 slower than the RTX
4070 that margin was reduced to 20 at
1440p which admittedly is still a big
performance Advantage for the GeForce
GPU even if it does cost 20 more then at
4K we're reduced to just 30 FPS with the
7800 XT which is a 25 performance
reduction when compared to the RTX 4070
though it was once again comparable
performance to the old 6800 XT moving on
to Resident Evil 4 with the ray tracing
quality preset we see that the 1700xt is
good for 157 FPS at 1080p which made it
10 faster than the 6800 XT and able to
match the RTX 4017 it falls away
slightly at 1440p though he had only
trailed the 4070 by a three percent
margin but was also just three percent
faster than the 6800 XT
now 4K we're still looking at very
playable performance from the 7800 XT
with 75 fps to match the RTX 3080 as
well as the 6800 XT and RTX 4070
amd's Ray tracing performance isn't up
to the task in cyberpunk 2077 as here
the 7800 XT falls behind the RTX 4070 by
a 22 margin at 1080p with just 58 FPS on
average and here we are using the medium
quality Ray tracing preset still the
7800 XT is priced to match the 16
gigabyte RTX 4060 TI and here it does
match that particular product's
performance the 7800 XT averaged just 36
FPS at 1440p making it 16 slower than
the 4070 but also six percent faster
than the 6800 XT and nine percent faster
than the RTX 4060 TI 16 gig then finally
at 4K none of the tested gpus are able
to deliver playable performance at the
native resolution
Ray tracing performance in Spider-Man
remastered is generally quite good and
we're certainly seeing that here with
the 1700xt at 1080p with 148 FPS on
average it matched the 6800 XT to come
in just five percent slower than the RTX
4070 now 1440p the new Radeon GPU is
nine percent slower than the 4070 with
120 FPS on average which also made it
seven percent faster than the 6800 XT
then finally at the 4K resolution the
7800 XT was good for 76 FPS on average
and this saw it match the 6800 XT to
come in at just eight percent slower
than the RTX 4070
the second last game that we're going to
look at Ray tracing performance with is
fortnite and here the 7800 XT actually
manages to outperform the RTX 4070 at
1080p delivering 7 more frames to hit 90
FPS this was also a seven percent uplift
over the 6800 XT so decent results there
the margin over the RTX 4070 shrank to 5
at 1440p and now the 7800 XT is just
able to average 60 FPS but that's still
a 9 boost over the 6800 XT then finally
we have the 4K resolution and sticking
to the native resolution so no upscaling
we're only seeing 30 FPS from the 7800
XT and RTX 4070. last up we have Star
Wars Jedi Survivor and here the 7800 XT
rendered 87 FPS on average which is the
same level of performance seen from the
6800 XT making the new Radeon GPU eight
percent slower than the RTX 4070 but 14
faster than the RTX 460 GI 16 gig
now at 1440p the 7800 XT is just six
percent slower than the RTX 4070 with 61
FPS on average which is the same level
of performance you receive from either
the 6800 XT or RTX 3080
then add the native 4K resolution we're
dropping down to just 32 FPS on average
so again the same performance you'll see
from the RTX 3080 and 6800 XT and around
six percent slower than the RTX 4070
okay so across the half dozen titles
that were tested with Ray tracing
enabled we found that at 1080p the 7800
XT was on average 10 slower than the RTX
4070 and on par with the RTX 3080 making
it ever so slightly faster than the 6800
XT it was also 15 faster than the
similarly priced RTX 4060 TI 16 gig so a
bit of a win there for a new Radeon GPU
then we see that the 7800 XT was good
for an average of 69 FPS at 1440p making
it nine percent slower than the RTX 4070
and 5 faster than the 6800 XT
now for those of you who are wanting to
take advantage of Ray tracing effects at
4K with these gpus it's not possible at
the native resolution and will without
question require the aid of upscaling
still relative to the RTX 4070 the 7800
XT does quite well here as it's just
seven percent slower
here's a look at how the 6800 XT and
7800 XT compared to head to head across
the half dozen RT titles on average the
newer rdna 3 GPU is offering a 5
performance Improvement so I guess
that's not nothing but the real win here
is the price and we'll look at that in a
moment
now the 7800 XT is set to cost 17 less
than the RTX 4070 so the fact it was
only eight percent slower on average
across the ray tracing tests we looked
at is a pretty good result the big
losses were seen in cyberpunk 2077 and a
plateau Requiem with the only wind
coming in the way of fortnite but
overall still not a bad result
here's a quick look at total system
power consumption in Hitman 3 and here
we see that the 7800 XT reduced total
system usage by 13 when compared to the
6800 XT for what amounted to roughly the
same level of performance the 7800 XT
was just four percent slower than the
RTX 470 in this example but here we see
that it pushed total system usage 15
higher which is quite a substantial
increase the Spider-Man results are a
little more favorable as here the 7800
XT reduced total system consumption by
nine percent when compared to the 6800
XT while we only saw a slightly lower 12
increase over the RTX 4070 still there's
no doubting the fact that the GeForce
GPU is more power efficient
all right so this is the cost per Frame
data calculated using the MSRP and the
results from our 15-game average as
expected the 7800 XT looks quite good
here delivering by far the best cost per
frame of any current or previous
generation GPU at least those that we've
tested when compared to the 6800 XT
we're looking at a 25 reduction in cost
per frame for the 7800 XT and a 21
reduction when compared to the RTX 4070
so while I'm sure the 7800 xt's
performance hasn't blown you away at
least the price isn't a disaster
even when compared to current retail
pricing the 700 XT fares very well
matching the value of the heavily
discounted RX 6800 so not amazing but
also much better than what we were
expecting prior to AMD announcing
pricing when compared to the heavily
discounted 530 us 6800 XTS the new 7800
XT is still eight percent better value
and again a 21 improvement over the RTX
4070 is impressive
now if we were to recalculate everything
using the ray tracing only data this is
what we'd find when looking at the msrps
the 7800 XT is still better value than
the RTX 4070 reducing the cost per frame
by eight percent and it would be a
massive 26 better value than the 6800 XT
that's assuming the 6800 XT was still
selling for 650 USD of course though
it's not and at the discounted 530 us
price the 7800 XT is just 10 better
value than the 6800 XT so not nothing
but hardly a worthwhile generational
uplift when put that way I guess it's
unfortunate that three years later
there's still so much rdna2 stock bit of
a whoopsie there from the ordering
Department
now before we wrap this review up here's
a look at the operating behavior of the
AMD reference model after an hour of
in-game load it hit a junction
temperature of 75 degrees Celsius with
the peak hotspot of 85c so pretty good
results there though the fans were
required to spin at 1600 RPM and were
audible over the case fans not super
loud but the reference card did make
itself known as for the courts they
typically clocked at 2160 megahertz when
testing in The Last of Us Part One at 4K
using the high quality settings and as
you can see this sucked up a lot of vram
Now power color's hellhound version is
much larger than the reference model and
in terms of operating behavior is much
more impressive the GPU Junction
temperature peaked at just 68 degrees
Celsius with a peak hotspot temperature
of 77c so 8C cooler than that of the AMD
reference card but that's not the whole
story the three fans spun at just 650
RPM to achieve those results making the
hellhound virtually silent in our test
system as it was much quieter than the
system itself interestingly though the
chords only clocked at 20 80 megahertz
on average during our test which is a
four percent reduction when compared to
the AMD reference model then we have the
XFX Mercury 319 and this model saw a
peak Junction temperature of 67c with
the peak hotspot temperature of 77c so
the same hot spot as the hellhound
however unlike the hellhound The Merc
319 clocked really well typically
operating at 22 70 megahertz that's nine
percent higher than that of the
hellhound the fans did run at 1200 RPM
but even so the card was virtually
silent and a 9 clock discrepancy is much
larger than you typically expect
okay so that was a lot of data and I
suspect many of you found the numbers
disappointing given that the 7800 XT is
basically a 6800 XT in terms of
performance that's hardly exciting stuff
after three years and in fact it's
borderline embarrassing for AMD the only
saving Gracie is the price because at
500 the 7800 XT will be the go-to option
for many
if we look at our cost per frame graph
again you can see why I suggested a 450
us asking price for the 7800 XT that
would have made it hands down the Best
Buy but you can also see why AMD didn't
push that hard because at 500 us there's
really nothing better in terms of value
than the 7800 XT
you're not going to bother with the RX
6800 at 430 and at 530 the 6800 XT is
now dead
prior to the release of the 1700 XT you
could make an argument for the 6800 XT
over the RTX 4070 though I think most
would have been happy to invest the
extra 70 or so in the GeForce GPU for
the greatly improved power efficiency
av1 support better Ray tracing
performance and dlss3 frame generation
13 isn't a huge premium to pay for those
features
but when compared to the 7800 XT the RTX
4070 is 20 more expensive both support
av1 encoding the ray tracing Gap is
reduced as is power efficiency leaving
dlss as the only real draw card for the
GeForce GPU now AMD has talked at length
about fsr3 and has made some pretty bold
claims while doing so but even now it's
still an upcoming feature so the RTX
4070 does have the benefit of dlss and
dlss frame generation still frame gen is
only going to be useful for some of you
so even once AMD gets fsr3 out a lot of
you won't actually care that being the
case for many gamers the 7800 XT and RTX
4070 are very evenly matched and with
the Radeon GPU 100 us cheaper it's now
the obvious option in my opinion
the bar might have been set low but even
so that's a solid achievement for AMD
the RTX 4070 is nvidia's best value
offering with more than eight gigabytes
of vram and in terms of value the 7800
XT crushes it offering more performance
and more vram at a much lower price it
also makes the RTX 46 DTI 16 gigabyte
look foolish but to be fair that GPU
looked like a clown show at 500 us long
before the 7800 XT was even a thing
overall this is the first good release
from AMD in their rgna3 Series so that's
a big positive even if it's coming nine
months after the initial release and
that's really all I can say about the
7800 XT it's a discounted 6800 XT with a
few improvements pretty crap really
after three years but you know given how
this generation has gone so far it's
good enough so with no choice really I
guess we'll take it and that's it for
this review of the AMD Radeon RX 7800 XT
of course the 7700 XT is also a GPU
that's available I believe now maybe
this is coming out like a day before the
actual launch date but 7700 XT we will
be reviewing that shortly as well so
stay tuned for that one once again this
was a video that was produced by Steve
so this is all his thoughts and Analysis
and things like that so fingers crossed
Steve can get better soon and be able to
present videos again on the channel
shortly but in the meantime you can give
him some best wishes in the comments
below or go down to the description and
look for our patreon and links because
if you sign up to those you'll be
supporting the independent testing that
goes into reviews such as this and
you'll get some cool benefits in the
meantime such as we've got our Discord
Community monthly live streams BTS
videos so lots of great stuff in there
so thanks for watching and we'll catch
you in the next one
[Music]
thank you